koalition mit dem titel zwei jahre nach
den rechts terroristischen morden von
hanau den kampf gegen rechtsextremismus
und hass entschieden weiterführen am 19
februar jährt sich der rassistische
anschlag von hanau zum zweiten mal
damals hatte der 43 jährige tobias r in
halle neun menschen aus rassistischen
motiven ermordet danach erschoss er
mutmaßlich seine mutter und dann sich
selbst über seine motive haben die
ermittler übrigens keinen zweifel der
paranoide täter hatte laut
bundeskriminalamt eindeutige
rassistisches weltbild er hinterließ ein
manifest mit vernichtungs fantasien die
ermittlungen zu diesem hanau anschlag
die sind übrigens ende letzten jahres
eingestellt worden nämlich der
attentäter hatte laut bundesanwaltschaft
keine hilfe oder mitwisser für die
angehörigen der opfer allerdings bleiben
weiter fragen der bundestags-
vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki hat in diesem moment
die aktuelle stunde angekündigt
und jetzt geht es gleich los
so ich hoffe die aussprache
erst um dem kollegen und mit nouripour
für fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen das
wort und der fraktionsvorsitzende von
bündnis 90 die grünen der verteidigung
der parteivorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen der hat das erste wort in dieser
aktuellen stunde er kommt hier auch aus
hessen
herr präsident meine
damen und herren wir
gedenken heute diejenigen die beim
rassistischen verbrechen am 19 februar
2020 in hanau ihr leben verloren dieser
tag ist leider eine von viel zu vielen
gedenktagen ein opfer rechter gewalt und
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass diese
menschen seiner zeit in einer statistik
werden das ist unsere verantwortung ihre
erinnerungen hoch zu halten und sie
nicht vergessen zu lassen und deshalb
kann man ihre namen auch nicht oft genug
sagen bekannt gültig
setup
seines
mercedes kippert hamza kurtovic willi
viorel
partie salat euro carlo janka kauf und
ferhat unwahr diese menschen sind viel
zu früh aus dem leben gerissen worden
weil aus hass schandtaten geworden ist
ein hass der uns alle bedroht davon
zeugen auch die feigen mörder an michael
kiesewetter wundern was lücke das ist
unsere gemeinsame verantwortung als
demokratinnen und demokraten
alles dafür zu tun damit sich ein
solches nicht wiederholt und allen
personen und parteien die diesen hass
verbreiten ein klares stopp schild
aufzustellen
damen und herren wir erleben dieser tage
das in der pandemie verunsicherte
menschen zusammen mit rechtsextremen
durch unsere straßen marschieren ich
kann diesen menschen nur zurufen lassen
sie sich von diesen hetzern nicht
instrumentalisieren rechtsextreme nutzen
nutzen die das verunsicherung sie nutzen
oder für see und verunsicherung um die
realität umzudeuten und um demokratisch
legitimierter politikerinnen und
politiker einzuschüchtern sie sind weder
das volk noch die mehrheit in diesem
land meine damen und herren es ist gut
dass in hessen die demokratischen
parteien bei allen differenzen sich auf
einen untersuchungsausschuss geeinigt
haben weil die angehörigen ein anrecht
haben auf die fragen die sie noch haben
die noch nicht beantwortet worden sind
und das ist bezeichnend dass die afd
nicht einmal der einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses zugestimmt hat
das ist schlicht
unanständig und ich hoffe dass der
verfassungsschutz in zukunft noch
deutlicher darstellen kann wes geistes
kind sie eigentlich sind
wenn unsere ehemaligen
bundestagspräsidentin wolfgang schäuble
sehr dankbar dass er bei der
bundestagsdebatte damals vor zwei jahren
diese deutlichen worte gefunden
natürlich zieht ihre betroffenheit
reicht längst nicht mehr hanau fordert
vor allem aufrichtigkeit aufrichtigkeit
vom staat der sich eingestehen muss die
rechtsextremistische gefahr zu lange
unterschätzt war zitat ende diese
aufrichtigkeit die damen und herren und
erkenntnis erfordert ein entschlossenes
handeln des staates und seiner
institutionen alle menschen die in
unserem staat dienen müssen dass auf der
grundlage der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung tun und die
allermeisten tun das hervorragend ich
möchte an dieser stelle sicher nicht nur
in meinem namen den polizisten und
polizisten danken die täglich tagtäglich
den kräften sich entgegenstellen die
unsere demokratie in frage stellt sie
haben dass
sie haben es sicher gesehen ein
polizeibeamter der bei einem dieser
sogenannten spaziergänge einem
teilnehmer zurief ich zitiere sie wolle
nicht spazieren gehen sie wollen uns
verarschen sie wollen hier die wollen
uns hier eindeutig an der nase
herumführen zitat ende und hat einfach
recht die demokratie ist wehrhaft wir
lassen uns nicht an der nase herumführen
hier
stehen zusammen gegen
rassisten in diesem haus und außerhalb
lassen sie uns gemeinsam die strukturen
und organisation stärken die die
unerlässliche bildungsarbeit vor ort
machen und den betroffenen von rechter
rechtsextremer und antisemitischer
gewalt als anlaufstelle auch helfen ist
also bereits bei hessen zu bleiben ich
möchte bei uns in frankfurt erwähnen die
bildungsstätte eine frank die auch den
hinterbliebenen der opfer in hanau hilft
oder die bildungsinitiative die frau
termin war die mutter von ferhat ins
leben gerufen hat die kindern und ihren
eltern eine anlaufstelle bietet wenn sie
diskriminierung erfahren ich möchte
diesen organisationen und vielen anderen
einfach nur meine hochachtung zum
ausdruck bringen und danke sagen ich hab
ja am rande der bundesversammlung frau
unwahr sprechen dürfen ich habe sie
gefragt was sie heute sagen würde wenn
sie an meiner stelle hier stehen könnte
und sie hat gesagt sag ihnen dass die
kinder in meiner bildungsstätte die
zukunft deutschlands sind wie alle
anderen kinder in unserem land auch
meine damen und herren lassen sie uns
zusammen stehen für diese zukunft sie
waren um nicht zulassen dass sie von
hass zerstört wird
[Applaus]
da hier die aktuelle stunde eröffnet hat
die von den regierungsfraktionen hier
beantragt worden ist ja im hessischen
landtag arbeitet ein parlamentarischer
untersuchungsausschuss offene fragen und
ungereimtheiten wie sehen die
angehörigen der opfer des rassistisch
motivierten attentats von hanno auch
nach fast zwei jahren der tat immer noch
andrea lindholz jetzt für die union
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
hanau liegt nur wenige autominuten von
meinem wahlkreis entfernt vor zwei
jahren wurden dort neun menschen
aufgrund ihrer vermeintlichen herkunft
ermordet die tat sie war eindeutig
rechtsterrorismus und klar rassistisch
motiviert heute sind unsere gedanken vor
allen dingen bei den familien der opfer
und ihnen rufe ich zu wir stehen
weiterhin an ihrer seite und der hass
darf in deutschland niemals
der politische auftrag für uns ist klar
jeder mensch soll sich in deutschland
sicher fühlen können egal welcher
herkunft man hat ob man politische
verantwortung trägt oder einfach nur
eine synagoge einen weihnachtsmarkt oder
die domplatte in köln besuchen möchte
und um diese sicherheit zu gewährleisten
brauchen unsere behörden auch moderne
befugnisse um zum beispiel hass in
seinen digitalen resonanz räumen wirksam
bekämpfen zu können
ideen wie unsere behörden hier besser
werden können habe ich weder im
koalitionsvertrag gefunden der ampel
noch heute im innenausschuss im bericht
der bundesinnenministerium vernommen
befugnisse sollen stattdessen
eingeschränkt und zusammengestrichen
werden
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was
wir brauchen ist ein gesellschaftlicher
zusammenhalt neben allem staatlichen ist
das gesellschaftliche
unglaublich wichtig denn die
wehrhaftigkeit unserer streitbaren
demokratie sie fängt bei jedem einzelnen
an indem man hass und hetze im netz auf
der arbeit oder wo auch immer man ihn
vor findet ganz klar widerspricht denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen aus
gedanken werden worte und manchmal
werden aus worten leider auch taten und
es sollte ein guter politischer konsens
unter den demokratischen parteien
herrschen dass es keinen guten
extremismus gibt und wir sollten jede
form von extremismus entschieden
ablehnen und das auch immer wieder
gemeinsam betont
der frühere bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer er hat bereits
2019 dem rechtsextremismus den krieg
erklärt die innenministerkonferenz hat
in der letzten wahlperiode beschlüsse
gefasst ein kabinettsausschuss hat 89
maßnahmen gegen rassismus auf den weg
gebracht die sicherheitsbehörden wurden
personell und strukturell massiv
gestärkt wir haben das waffenrecht
verschärft und das netz dg wir haben
eine zentralstelle beim bka zur
strafverfolgung von hass im netz hass im
netz geschaffen das bka hat seine sein
system zur überwachung der
islamistischen gefährder auf die
rechtsextremisten auf rechtsextremisten
übertragen und es laufen struktur
ermittlungsverfahren die wir auch gerade
im parlamentarischen kontrollgremium
vorangetrieben haben gemeinsam und die
viel licht ins dunkel bringen der blick
der behörden hat sich zur aufdeckung von
netzwerken und kennt verhältnissen stark
verändert und verbessert der
verfassungsschutz hat eine neue
abteilung die extremismus im
öffentlichen dienst beobachtet und wir
das parlament haben eine million eine
milliarde euro zusätzlich für
präventionsprogramme bereitgestellt das
sind nur einige beispiele
und ja es ist fakt der rechtsextremismus
ist eine zentrale bedrohung für die
sicherheit in deutschland und wir haben
diesen kampf in den vergangenen jahren
auf breiter front aufgenommen das hat
gerade auch horst seehofer mit
vorangetrieben und er war oft bei uns im
innenausschuss liebe frau feser und ich
habe heute vernommen dass auch sie den
austausch mit dem ausschuss suchen
werden und der kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus er darf nicht mit
ideologischen scheuklappen geführt
werden aber sie haben uns bei ihrem
kampf dann auch an ihrer seite
ich habe es schon im januar gesagt
gewalttäter der antifa sind keine hilfe
im kampf gegen rechtsextremismus und ich
muss heute auch mit blick auf die neue
bundesinnenministerium ergänzen auch die
autorenschaft für eine
linksextremistisch beeinflussten
vereinigung ist ein no-go
[Applaus]
es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten
um gastbeiträge zu transportieren das
war eine denkbar schlechte wahl und es
geht nicht um rollen die wir spielen es
geht nicht um rollen die man als
innenministerin spielt wie man in der
bild am sonntag lesen konnte es geht um
das richtige gespür für rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien und mit einem artikel für
eine vereinigung für die sich der
verfassungsschutz nicht nur in bayern
interessiert setzt man sich in jeder
politischen rolle dem vorwurf aus am
linken rand zu fischen und das schade
dem eigentlichen anliegen das schadet
dem berechtigten anliegen denn der
rechtsstaatliche kampf gegen den
gravierenden
rechtsextremismus er kann nur gewonnen
werden wenn er mit aller
entschlossenheit mit konkreten
befugnissen und frei von links
war es für die cdu csu fraktion und
die nächste rednerin hat sie schon
angesprochen wir haben ja auch schon im
bild gesehen doch etwas etwas weniger
emotionale debatte in die profi antar
hintergrund hat angemessen wegekreuzung
dass man zu sagen auch bei der linken
klatsch gelegentlich die afg und das zu
den initiatoren schlussfolgerungen
führen könnte und ich will darauf hin
ich will darauf hinweisen dass ich will
darauf hinweisen dass die masken das
negativ ist etwas positives an das
negative ist man kann hier nichts
verstehen
das könnte auch positiv sein also man
hört ja nur im allgemeinen ist ein
allgemeiner geräuschkulisse das wird der
sache nicht angemessen spiel nur darauf
hinweisen bei diesem thema entgegen
sonstigen gepflogenheit möchte ich eine
rede äußerst unfair unterbrechen aber
ich will darauf hinweisen dass die
aktuellen stunde gegen fünf minuten ein
konsequentes zeitmanagement hat und ich
bitte darum dass auch wirklich zu
beachten das heißt wenn die lampe blinkt
da vorne frau kolleginnen andere dann
sollte man wirklich auch zum ende kommen
ist doch viel lieber einen anderen
redner in dieser debatte
als nächstes jahr in den nächsten rennen
haben wir schon gesehen da sitzt sie auf
der regierungsbank das ist nancy faeser
die bundesinnenministerium
bundesinnenministerium sie war bis zum
dezember letzten jahres
fraktionsvorsitzender der spd im
hessischen landtag
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren frau kollegin lindholz sie
sollten sie haben hiervon richtigen
gespür gesprochen sie sollten endlich
dazu übergehen wenn es um eine form des
extremismus geht nicht immer reflexartig
den anderen hervorholen und das
ausgerechnet in dieser debatte
anlässlich des zweiten jahrestages von
hanau fand ich mehr als unangemessen
und obwohl ich es unangemessen für die
süchtigen einsatz noch wenn sie mit mir
hier über eine klare abgrenzung zum
linksextremismus reden werde ich auch da
zu reden und ganz klar mich dort gegen
linksextremismus stellen und nicht
reflexartig nach rechts gucken
vielleicht lernen sie davon auch was für
ihre äußerungen gegenüber dieses
phänomen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wir werben gültig in servus sagt lisa
haschemi
mercedes kirberg hamza coach willi view
relativ sarah chalke luv erhard unwahr
und carlo janka kof nie vergessen sie
fehlen
sie alle hatten viel vor in ihrem leben
für sie alle war hier zu hause sie
wurden mit entsetzlicher brutalität
ermordet viele familien haben das
schlimmste passiert was ihnen passieren
kann sie haben ihre kinder verloren
der rassistische terroranschlag in hanau
hat unser ganzes land zutiefst
erschüttert der 19 februar 2020 bleibt
ein tiefer einschnitt für unser land in
dieser woche gedenken wir der opfer
und heute haben wir im kabinett
beschlossen ab diesem jahr ist der elfte
märz der nationale gedenktag für opfer
terroristischer gewalt wir wollen dass
das schicksal der opfer und ihrer
angehörigen uns alle in staat und
gesellschaft bewusster wird wir wollen
dass die stimmen der opfer gehört werden
und ihre perspektive zählt wir wollen
die familien der opfer mit mehr empathie
und mit mehr sensibilität unterstützen
in allen staatlichen ebenen
meine damen und herren viele menschen in
hanau kannten die ermordeten der täter
kannte seine opfer nicht und doch wollte
er genau sie treffen er ermordete neun
menschen weil sie eine
einwanderungsgeschichte haben in seinem
mörderischen rassismus seinem
fanatischen hass und verschwörungsdenken
erklärte er sie zu fremden das waren sie
aber nicht sie waren teil unserer
gesellschaft daran dürfen wir als staat
nicht den geringsten zweifel lassen
das schicksal der angehörigen der
ermordeten treibt mich sehr um viele
habe ich kennengelernt und
hatte viele persönliche begebenheiten
und kontakte und ich werde auch am
samstag bei ihm seien deshalb sage ich
auch hier ganz deutlich der staat
schuldet den familien der opfer eine
transparente und lückenlose aufarbeitung
aller hintergründe diesen entsetzlichen
anschlag
wir der bund und das land hessen haben
die schlicht aufzuklären nur so haben
die angehörigen die möglichkeit mit dem
grauenvollen geschehen leben zu können
und nur so kann das tief verletzte
vertrauen in unseren staat wieder
wachsen dann den angehörigen aber auch
bei anderen menschen die immer wieder
rassistische angriffe erleben dieser
anschlag hatte eine wirkung weit über
hanau hinaus viele von uns können sich
gar nicht vorstellen was es bedeutet
wenn rassismus zum alltag gehört zwei
jahre nach dem anschlag sind noch viele
offene fragen offen der
untersuchungsausschuss im hessischen
landtag bietet nun endlich die chance
für eine umfassende aufarbeitung als
hessischer landespolitikerin habe ich
mich sehr dafür eingesetzt als
bundesinnenministerium werde ich alles
dafür tun dass auch von seiten des
bundes transparent und umfassender
unterstützung erfolgt das ist eine frage
der empathie und der verantwortung und
das ist mein verständnis von einem staat
der aus versäumnissen und fehlern lernt
ein staat der handelt und konsequenzen
zieht dieser anschlag kam nicht aus dem
nichts und der geschah auch alles andere
als zufällig die spur des rechten
terrors zieht sich auch durch unsere
jüngere geschichte
solingen mölln hoyerswerda der terror
der nsu der anschlag am münchner olympia
einkaufszentrum der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten meinem ehemaligen
kollegen dr walter lübke der terror von
halle und hanau wer ist vorher noch
nicht verstanden oder verharmlost hat
der muss es nach hanau endlich klar sein
der rechtsextremismus ist die schlimmste
bedrohung unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung
und deshalb hat die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus
unsere höchste priorität wir werden
alles tun um die menschen die in unserem
land bedroht und angegriffen werden
besser zu schützen wir sind eine
wehrhafte demokratie
wir bekämpfen die feinde der offenen
gesellschaft wir bekämpfen jede form von
extremismus mit aller kraft diese gewalt
hat einen nährboden ein
menschenfeindliches klima dass
gewaltbereite extremisten
anstachelt und im schlimmsten fall zur
tat schreiten lässt geistige
brandstifter schön diesen hass bewusst
sie liefern die mentale munition für
solche taten diese hetzer wissen was sie
tun sie haben unterstützer die menschen
hass und rassismus auch aus unseren
parlamenten heraus verbreiten ich kann
ihnen sagen wir stellen uns jeder
menschenverachtung ganz entschieden
entgegen hier und überall in unserem
land
und ich sage auch sie werden sich an
eine frau mit einer klaren haltung an
der spitze des bundesinnenministeriums
gewöhnen müssen
wir setzen alles daran den nährboden für
rechtsextreme gewalt auszutrocknen vom
ersten tag am abend habe ich einen
klaren kurs eingeschlagen um die
eskalation von hass und gewalt zu
stoppen wir haben die ermittlungen des
bundeskriminalamtes deutlich
intensiviert und wir haben deutlichen
druck auf die plattformen wie telegramm
aufgebaut und ich kann heute sagen dass
wir erste erfolge haben ich bin stolz
darauf dass wir von 68 angemeldeten wird
zu löschen den seiten jetzt 64 gelöscht
wurden ich bin froh dass wir das
erreichen konnten dass hass und hetze im
übrigen auch gegen kommunalpolitiker und
andere die verantwortung tragen nun
gelöscht wurden und darum darf ich mich
auch sehr herzlich bedanken
das ist ein anfang wir werden weiter
aufdrängen dass das unternehmen den
gesetzlichen pflichten nachkommt
morddrohungen und andere gefährliche
hass post müssen gelöscht werden und
deutliche strafrechtliche konsequenzen
haben wir müssen hetzer schnelle
identifizieren und zur verantwortung
ziehen ich habe es hier an dieser stelle
im januar angekündigt als
bundesinnenministerium werde ich bis
ostern einen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus vorlegen wir setzen
alles daran radikalisierung zu stoppen
und rechtsextreme netzwerke zu
zerschlagen
wir werden die finanzströme der
extremisten verfolgen und ihre
einnahmenquellen ihnen nehmen und wir
werden sehr konsequent die waffen
entziehen
doch tief verwurzelte
menschenfeindlichkeit konsequent zu
begegnen ist nicht allein die aufgabe
einer starken polizei und gut
ausgestatteten sicherheitsbehörden es
ist auch die aufgabe von uns allen als
gesellschaft deshalb werden wir
gesellschaftliches engagement politische
bildung und extremismus prävention
stärken wir werden das demokratische
engagement unzähliger vereine verbände
initiativen der kollegin um nouripour
hat das genannt und in ganz deutschland
endlich verlässlich und umfassend
fördern
das ist die beste antwort auf
menschenverachtung intoleranz und gewalt
deshalb werden familienministerin eine
spiegel und ich dass demokratie
fördergesetz auch schnell auf den weg
bringen meine damen und herren
frau ministerin
wir werden uns an die opfer des 19
februar 2020 in hannover immerhin
einbürgern gültekin sedaris seiten hin
leser haschimi mercedes kierpiec hansa
coach willi viorel braun fathi sarah
jacqueline fehr hat unser und kalorien
bake off bleiben immer in unserer
erinnerung sie vielen vielen dank
heute unter anderem beschlossen dass der
elfte märz künftig zum bedenkt tag für
opfer terroristischer gewalt
erklärt werden soll das knüpft an den
europäisch mit dem tag für die opfer des
terrorismus
das hat die ministerin hier noch mal
bekräftigt und bis ostern hat sie
angekündigt einen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus und
für unter anderem noch immer bestätigt
dass sie eine weitere verschärfung des
waffenrechts anstrebt und das demokratie
fördergesetz auf den weg bringen will
dies beides war in der letzten
legislatur noch gescheitert
als nächster in das rot der kollege dr
christian wirth der sich ohne mein
aufführung bereits einen platz gegeben
hat herr kollege 40 jahren das war
präsident werden kollegen in diesem land
da ist kein platz für irgendwelche
extremismus geben das soll da ich
konsens und diesem hause sein zwei jahre
sind seit der bluttat von hanau
vergangen der zehn menschen zum opfer
fielen bevor sich der täter selbst
richtete ein tag der so gut wie jedem
bundesbürger noch in erinnerung sein
wird und an dem ganz deutschland
schockiert und in trauer mit den
hinterbliebenen der opfer stand das
kranke weltbild des täters
manifestiert er sich in einigen videos
auf seinem youtube kanal und vor allem
in seinem manifest welches er auf seiner
internetseite veröffentlicht der
offenkundige psychisch zutiefst gestörte
täter äußert unternehmen rassistischen
gedankengut abstruse
verschwörungstheorien es seit seit
seiner geburt von einem geheimdienst
beobachtet worden der seine gedanken
lesen und andere menschen steuern könne
dieser unterhaltung auch unterirdische
militärbasen in der usa in denen kinder
gequält und der teufel an gebildet würde
er selbst plane mittels einer
zeitschleife in die vergangenheit zu
fliegen um die erde zu zerstören bevor
sich leben auf ihr entwickeln kann um
nur einen kleinen einblick in seine
wahnvorstellung zu geben es ist wahr ich
absurd aber nichts kann auch absurd
genug sein dass die politische
konkurrenz dieses diese gedankenwelt
nicht mit der alternative wird
deutschland in verbindung bringen will
um aus dieser schrecklichen tat
politisches kleingeld zu schlagen
als beispiel möchte ich den kollegen
kurz in den coolen zitieren der ja auch
gerne mal die moralischen zeigefinger
erhebt der wortwörtlich auf twitter
schrieb das pamphlet des täters von
hanno liest sich wie eine rede von
godfrey kury ofd im deutschen bundestag
in worte die frage die sich uns heute
stellt ist
hätte die tat von hanau verhindert
werden können und welche lehren ziehen
wir auch für die zukunft bei genauer
betrachtung der chronologie eröffnet
sich eine ganze reihe von fällen
erheblichen behörden versagens bereits
im jahre 2002 erlangte man kenntnis von
der psychischen störung erst als er beim
polizeipräsidium oberfranken eine
anzeige erstattete man hört höre ihnen
durch die steckdose seiner wohnung ab
der amtsarzt stellte daraufhin eine
psychose aus dem schizophrenen
formenkreis mit paranoiden inhalten fest
und pfahl die sofortige einweisung in
die psychiatrie aus dem krankenhaus
wurde am selben abend und gehalt
entlassen
2004 stellte eine weitere anzeige es
folgten weitere ermittlungen wegen
diverser delikte beispielsweise wegen
angriffs auf einen wachmann der
universität bayreuth und
drogenschmuggels trotz alldem erhielt er
im jahre 2013 an waffenbesitzkarte die
auch nach weiteren ermittlungen mit
wegen fahrlässiger brandstiftung und
erneutem troge schmucks nicht entzogen
wurde selbst oberste behörden erlangten
kenntnisse über den geisteszustand
erster er kurz vor seiner tat im
november 2009 10 eine strafanzeige bei
der general bundesanwaltschaft ging eine
unbekannte geheimdienstliche
organisation stellte deren inhalt
größtenteils identisch mit dem zuvor von
mir erwähnten abstrusen manifest ist
dass dieser fall vermutlich eher mit
einer psychiatrischen behandlung hätte
verhindert werden können als mit
extremismus prävention soll natürlich
nicht bedeuten dass extremismus
prävention nicht dringend angezeigt wäre
außer statistik des bundeskriminalamtes
zur politisch motivierten kriminalität
lassen sich besorgniserregende zahlen
entnehmen die uns alle angehen sollten
stellvertretend möchte ich aus dem
phänomenbereich politisch
motivierte gewalttaten nämlich
körperverletzung und dürften
tötungsdelikte des jahres zu 120 2020
1092 delikte von rechts und
1526 legte von links als zahlen nennen
im vergleich zum vorjahr verzeichnen wir
einen anstieg um 10,5 prozent bei
rechten gewalt haben und sagten 45 06
prozent bei linken gewalttaten dass
unsere neue investoren feser im magazin
anti vaters linksextremistischen vvn bda
einen artikel veröffentlicht hat lässt
nichts gutes hoffen was die bekämpfung
des linken extremismus angeht
ebenfalls zu nennen ist das
besorgniserregende personenpotenzial im
bereich islamismus islamischer
terrorismus aus dem
verfassungsschutzbericht 2020 die
relevanten sicherheitskreise dass
gemeinsamen analyse und strategie
zentrums illegale migration kurz gas
befürchten jetzt ein rasanter anstieg
von gefährder zahlen aufgrund der
einwanderungspolitik relation namentlich
der ministerien feser und bernburg auch
hierüber wird noch zu reden sein zum
schluss bleibt uns allen zu hoffen dass
es uns künftig gelingen wird solche
schrecklichen taten wie die von hand zu
verhindern in gedanken bei den opfern
und den hinterbliebenen und vielen dank
doch der wirt christian wirth war das
für die afg fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt
hier in dieser aktuellen stunde als
nächster redner wenn er mit strasser
hier sehen wir einen schöne bild das ist
der parlamentarische staatssekretär im
bundesjustizministerium
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kolleginnen und kollegen vor zwei jahren
wurden bei einem rassistischen
anschlagen hanau neun menschen brutal
ermordet für die neuen familien deren
freundin bekannt ist die welt seitdem
eine andere geliebte menschen fehlen sie
fehlen als eltern als kinder als
geschwister als arbeitskollegen und zu
diesem menschlichen polus verlust
mischen sich oft weitere ängste und
finanzielle sorgen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen genau deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass wir heute diese debatte führen das
schicksal der betroffenen in den
mittelpunkt stellt
nach dem anschlag gab es eine große
anteil haben viele zeichen der
solidarität und auch die bundesregierung
und verschiedene landesregierungen haben
geholfen durch finanzielle unterstützung
und andere praktische und psychologische
hilfe und trotzdem trotzdem müssen wir
uns eingestehen dass hin zu vielen
fällen nicht angemessen und umsichtig
genug mit den betroffenen von anschlägen
umgegangen würde und umgegangen wird
wenn überlebende wie citrix haschemi
berichten dass sie noch im krankenhaus
von der polizei aufgesucht und im rahmen
einer gefährderansprache aufgefordert
wurden zitat keine straftaten zu begehen
sich an niemandem zu rechnen und die
füße stillzuhalten zitat ende dann
sollte uns das im höchsten maß zu denken
geben andere angehörige wiederum
beklagen eine mangelnde kommunikation
sowie an zu bürokratischen umgang liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir müssen
besser werden und wir wollen auch besser
werden und deswegen der frau
bundesministerin käse war es heute so
ein wichtiges und starkes zeichen dass
sie gemeinsam mit dem
bundesjustizministerium im kabinett
beantragt haben den elften märz zum
nationalen gedenktag für die opfer
terroristische gewalt zu erheben nicht
nur weil es ein wunsch der betroffenen
fahrern es ist auch ein signal an die
opfer die überlebenden die angehörigen
nicht nur von hanau ihr leid ist nicht
vergessen es ist eine stetige mahnungen
der aufgabe insbesondere an
verbesserungen der opfer betreuung und
nachsorge zu arbeiten und genau das wird
die bundesregierung tun wir wir werden
lücken im opfern james
recht konsequent schließen wir werden
die koordinierungsstelle nachsorge opfer
und angehörigen hilfe nur auch für die
tätigkeit bei anschlägen in deutschland
öffnen und so das bereits bestehende
know-how im umgang mit opfern weiter
professionalisieren und ausbauen die
betroffenen von terroristischen und
extremistischen anschlägen erfahren
unermessliches individuelles leid doch
jeder dieser anschläge richtet sich auch
gegen unsere offene und vielfältige
gesellschaft umso mehr ist es pflicht
und aufgabe diese bundesregierung stetig
an der bestmöglichen versorgung zu
arbeiten die nsu terrorserie und die
schrecklichen anschläge vom
breitscheidplatz von halle und hanau
zeigen ausrotten können taten werden
allen anschlägen ist eine massive
radikalisierung der täterinnen und täter
vorausgegangen
und es ist eben auch das
gesellschaftliche klima das zu einer
solchen radikalisierung bei trägt
wir sollten deshalb nicht nur im
parlament
auf unserem portal und dem umgang
untereinander achten sondern auch
beleidigung volksverhetzung mord aufrufe
verfolgen die straftaten sind egal ob
online oder offline sie sind straftaten
und deswegen wird die neue
bundesregierung alle mittel eines
freiheitlichen und demokratischen
rechtsstaats nutzen um solche straftaten
konsequent zu ahnden zu verfolgen so hat
der bundesjustizminister gemeinsam mit
dem bundesinnenministerium die gangart
gegenüber plattformen wie teleplan
deutlich verschärft es steht eben nicht
im belieben eines unternehmens ob es
sich an deutsches recht halten möchte
oder nicht auf straftaten verfolgt
werden oder nicht und deswegen werden
wir darüber hinaus gemeinsam als
bundesregierung mit der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft uns dafür einsetzen
über dem digital services act zeitnah
ein effektives rechtsstaatliches
instrument der plattform regulierung in
europa zu etablieren
wir müssen den verhandlungsdruck wir
müssen im fahndungsdruck im netz erhöhen
damit diejenigen die sich dort strafbar
machen das nicht mehr in der gewissheit
tun können dass ihm keine konsequenzen
drohen die praxis zeigt in der regel
fehlen den behörden nicht die befugnisse
sollen die kapazitäten um straftaten zu
verfolgen und deswegen sind auch die
länder der verantwortung beispielsweise
internet streifen einzurichten die hier
einen ganz wichtigen beitrag leisten
können aber bei allem was getan worden
ist und was noch zu tun ist müssen wir
ehrlich sein in einer offenen freien
gesellschaft werden wir anschläge nie
ganz verhindern können
die letzte satz die betroffenen haben
aber den berechtigten anspruch dass wir
aus fehlern lernen und konsequenzen
ziehen dass der tod dieser menschen
dieser schlimme tod nicht umsonst war
nicht nur eine mahnung ist sondern dass
er ein auftrag bleibt vielen herzlichen
dank
niemand der straße tätig war schuldlos
am
main event strasser parlamentarische
staatssekretär im
bundesjustizministerium
nächste hier in dieser aktuellen stunde
ist yann in whistler sie ist die
parteivorsitzende der linken und war bis
vergangenes jahr fraktionsvorsitzende
der linken im hessischen landtag
am 19 februar 2020 wohnen hanau neun
menschen aus rassistischen motiven
ermordet
fahrradunfall hamster popovic zeitmesser
chemie will ebay powerseller skid pad
kalorien werk wo party sarah chalke sela
görges und gökay gültekin
danach tötete der täter seine mutter und
sich selbst in wenigen minuten starben
neun junge menschen die ihren abend mit
freunden verbrachten die gearbeitet
haben oder sich etwas zu essen gekauft
haben morde so wahllos und doch so
gezielt weil der täter menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte töten wollte das
war sein motiv unsere solidarität gilt
den angehörigen der opfer unsere
solidarität gilt den überlebenden von
hannah
hanna ist kein einzelfall und rechter
terror kein neues phänomen das
oktoberfest attentat rostock mölln und
solingen die mord serie das nsu münchen
der mord an walter lübke der anschlag
auf die synagoge in halle über 200
menschen wurden seit 1990 durch rechte
gewalt getötet immer wieder trauern
familien fühlen menschen sich schutzlos
werden opfer verdächtigt erinnern wir
uns an den umgang der familien der
ns-opfer die kriminalisiert wurden statt
hilfe zu erfahren weil man nicht glauben
wollte dass die täter rechte terroristen
sind rechter terror und rechte netzwerk
wurden viel zu lange verharmlost und
nicht ernst genommen die opferfamilien
von hanau fordern erinnerungen
gerechtigkeit aufklärung und
konsequenzen
erinnerungen damit die tat und die namen
der opfer nicht vergessen werden es darf
keinen schlussstrich geben aufklärung
heißt fehler der behörden im vorfeld und
in der tat nach zu untersuchen armin
foto vich ersatzvater vermutet dass
vieles anders offen wäre wenn die opfer
stefan und marie geheißen und in weil
dieses bierkeller stadt in einer shisha
bar gesessen hätten wäre auch ein
schwerverletzter deutsche ohne
migrationshintergrund
von der polizei als erstes nach seinem
ausweis gefragt worden und die abfahrt
des krankenwagens verzögert worden die
initiative neunzehnter februar die
angehörigen haben versucht ihr verlauf
der tat zu rekonstruieren die stießen
auch viele ungereimtheiten und sprechen
von einer kette des versagens warum
besaß der täter legal waffen obwohl er
auffällig war warum lief in der nacht
notrufe ins leere auch der von die von
genivi uhr elbauen die täter der den
täter verfolgt hat der menschen schützen
wollte und dabei ermordet wurde welche
rolle spielt der vater das theater ist
etwas rassistisches weltbild seines
sohnes teilt der die tatwaffen
zurückverlangt hat und er weiterhin in
der nachbarschaft der opferfamilien bund
warum gab es nach der tat
gefährderansprachen an die opferfamilien
warum keine gefährdeten ansprache diese
fragen quer in die familien seit zwei
jahren und einen hessen versucht ein
untersuchungsausschuss diese fragen
jetzt in teilen zu beantworten solange
diese fragen nicht beantwortet sind
fehler und verantwortung nicht benannt
sind kommen die familien nicht zur ruhe
und sie haben ein recht auf aufklärung
wir haben ein recht auf konsequenzen und
auf unterstützung gesammelt teil der
rechte gewalt und recht die terror wäre
er muss die recht netzwerke erkennen der
muss die szene konsequent entwaffnen es
muss schluss sein mit dem gerede von
einzelfällen und einzeltätern und wir
müssen den strukturellen den
alltäglichen rassismus auf allen
gesellschaftlichen ebenen und auch in
staatlichen institutionen bekämpfen
rassismus antisemitismus und
antizionismus dürfen keinen platz haben
und hören wir den menschen zu wenn sie
erzählen wie ein würdigen das ist immer
und immer wieder anlass sind
polizeikontrollen zu kommen wie
schwierig es ist mit einem
nicht-deutschen namen eine wohnung zu
finden dass man bei der polizei oft
nicht ernst genommen wird oder sogar
verdächtigt wird wenn man doch hilfe
sucht verrats mutter seppel ungefragt
warum müssen eltern ihren kindern
erklären dass sie sich in der schule
mehr anstrengen müssen weil sie nicht
die gleichen chancen haben die andere
dieses gefühl nicht dazuzugehören anders
behandelt zu werden vorurteilen
ausgesetzt zu werden das müssen wir
überwinden die sbb diskriminierung bei
der arbeitsplatzsuche bei behörden auf
dem wohnungsmarkt und in der schule die
müssen beseitigt werden der strukturelle
rassismus bekämpft werden meine damen
und herren und wir müssen die geistigen
brandstifter benennen wie vor ein klima
sorgen in dem sich täter ermutigt fühlen
und wer von messer männern
kopftuchmädchen und anderen taugen sich
zum spricht wer muslime kranken und
geflüchtet diffamiert die verbrechen der
nazizeit relativiert wie afg das tut
schafft einen nährboden für rechte
gewalt unsere solidarität gilt den
menschen die opfer von rechts diese
drohung werden und unsere solidarität
gilt all denen die sich tagtäglich
engagieren gegen rassismus die sich den
rechten den weg stellen weil die sind
dort der beste verfassungsschutz in
diesem land geben die gefahr von rechts
brauchen wir breite mobilisierungen ihr
rauchen bündnisse wie die omas gegen
rechts wie black lies matters wir
brauchen antifa bündnis und aufstehen
gegen rassismus die wie
gesellschaftliche initiativen und
beratungsangebote müssen gestärkt und
finanziell besser ausgestattet werden
und zum schluss die opfer von hanau sind
nicht vergessen und ihre angehörigen
fordern zu recht
planung darf keine weitere station des
rechten terror sein
muss die endstation sein
janine bis klar war dass die
parteivorsitzende der linken gesagt
einige der fragen gestellt die der
untersuchungsausschuss im hessischen
landtag sich
weiterhin stellen wird auch hat sie
angesprochen die initiative 19 februar
hanau das sind 1 angehörige freunde
der opfer von hanau die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben und die
ebenfalls eine lückenlose aufklärung und
konsequenzen aus der tat nach wie vor
fordern
hakan demir für die es billigend meine
damen und herren ich war 35 jahre alt
und noch nie in meinem leben wollte ich
deutschland verlassen doch dann kam
hanau neun junge mund menschen wurden
ermordet menschen wie sie und ich
menschen die gedichte schrieben menschen
die heiraten an leben haben wollten
niemand wird den schmerz und das leid
der hinterbliebenen nachempfinden können
dafür ist der schmerz zu groß viele der
hinterbliebenen haben die zimmer der
opfer unberührt gelassen die bettwäsche
ist nicht abgezogen es ist wichtig dass
wir hier gemeinsam gedenken denn der
anschlag auf ihre söhne und töchter ihre
schwestern und brüder mütter und väter
war ein anschlag auf uns alle
aber da ist noch etwas anderes etwas das
über trauer und anteilnahme hinausgeht
der täter von hanau hat seine opfer
nicht zufällig ausgewählt er hat nicht
zufällig die bar rabatte die shisha bar
mit neid und die arena war mit ihrem
angrenzenden kurs ausgewählt
er tat dies weil er wusste dass dort
menschen arbeiten und ihren feierabend
verbringen die gültekin unwahr goebbels
haschemi petkovic saratow verkauf und
paul hießen er tat es aus hass auf
menschen die als ausländer war nahm der
in seinem rassismus nicht als deutsche
akzeptieren konnte und wir wissen hanau
ist kein einzelfall noch an diesem
montag habe ich die familie und freunde
von burak beck das in meinem wahlkreis
berlin neukölln getroffen er wäre an
diesem montag 32 jahre alt geworden er
wurde getötet auf offener straße ich
hatte seine mutter mal gefragt was wir
als politiker innen tun können sie sagte
findet einfach den mörder meines sohnes
gestern sprach ich kurz mit abdullah
unwahr dem corsa von pferd und war er
fand diesen gedanken noch wichtig der
großvater von fährt unwahrheit straßen
in hanau gebaut denn der täter genutzt
hat
großvater hat also etwas aufgebaut aber
es gibt menschen in diesem land die
zerstören wollen das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen straßen können vielleicht
neutral sein aber wir dürfen es nicht
sein
nach der tat in hanau wurde von einem
fremdenfeindlichen anschlag gesprochen
ein anschlag auf fremde den hana langen
oder offenbach geboren wurden nein sie
sind keine ausländer keine fremden waren
sie auch noch nie sie sind ein teil von
uns und wir werden es auch um sie werden
es auch immer bleiben
zugegeben dieser rassismus in dieser
gesellschaft kann dazu führen dass
menschen unserer gesellschaft den rücken
kehren es wäre nur zu verständlich
stattdessen leisten die opferfamilien
aufklärungsarbeit und klagen vermehrt
versäumnisse an sie erzählen ihre
geschichte lassen das andenken an die
opfer nicht verblassen und sie
engagieren sich in der kommunalpolitik
und initiativen diese kraft ist einfach
beeindruckend
und auch andere menschen schöpfen kraft
aus ihrem beispiel so weiß ich dass
viele kolleginnen hier in diesem raum
erst recht gesagt haben sie wollen für
den bundestag kandidieren
nur um einige zu nennen kw mansouri
prima bali radovan sender ab die
beispielsweise nur eine einige der
wenigen kollegen und kolleginnen ich war
35 jahre alt und noch nie in meinem
leben wollte ich deutschland verlassen
dann kam hanau aber ich bin geblieben
wie viele andere auch denn das hier ist
auch unser land denn das ist auch unsere
sache wir werden nicht vergessen wir
werden nicht weichen unser weg hin zu
einer offenen und solidarischen
gesellschaft geht weiter vielen dank
hat man mir war das für die spd fraktion
hat er gesprochen seine erste rede hier
direkt gewählte abgeordnete aus dem
wahlkreis berlin neukölln und wir haben
einen wechsel im präsidium die
sitzungsleitung hat jetzt die
bundestagsvize präsidentin yvonne max
und ich erteile ebenfalls zu seiner
ersten rede das wort michael palmen cdu
csu fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der anschlag vom 19 februar
2020 in hanau war ein schrecklicher
einschnitt für unser land und die
kaltblütigkeit und sinnlosigkeit dieser
tat lässt viele von uns mich auch zwei
jahre später immer noch fassungslos
zurück
doch ich will ja auch feststellen ich
glaube es ist angebracht ist hat noch
mal zu sagen die opfer wurden von einem
täter mit menschenfeindlicher
rechtsextremistischen rassistische
gesinnung mitten aus dem leben gerissen
und brutal ermordet und da kann es keine
psychologischen relativierung oder
deutungen zu geben
und der schreckliche anschlag mahnt und
verpflichtet uns zu konsequentem handeln
gegen menschenfeindlichkeit rassismus
und rechtsextremismus
und ich bin dankbar dass so viele
menschen bundesweit in unserem land in
diesen tagen auch in meiner heimatregion
im kreis recklinghausen der opfer
gedenken und wir begrüßen es auch dass
der elfte märz als nationaler gedenktag
für opfer terroristischer gewalt ab
sofort gilt das ist ein gutes und
richtiges zeichen
denn die familien und angehörigen der
opfer sollen wissen sie sind nicht
allein wir sind in gedanken und in
unserem persönlichen politischen
handelns bei
und ihnen sind wir es schuldig die tat
und ihre umstände vollständig
aufzuklären die
opfer von hanau sind und waren ein
vollwertiger teil unserer gesellschaft
welche lebt verdient schutz vor hass und
gewalt aber ich möchte dem eindruck so
ein bisschen entgegen wirken dass es
jetzt etwas gegen rechtsextremismus
wirklich getan wird die unionsgeführte
bundesregierung hat in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode
da waren die sozialdemokraten auch mit
dabei ein umfangreiches maßnahmenpaket
gegen rassismus und rechtsextremismus
auf den weg gebracht es ist ein katalog
mit 89 einzelmaßnahmen für mehr
forschung mehr prävention und wirksam
opferschutz das kann man hier auch mal
deutlich sagen und darauf können darauf
müssen wir aufbauen und diesen weg
konsequent weitergehen und diesen
katalog auch umsetzen
und ich denke was die lehren aus dieser
schrecklichen tat angeht da gibt es
zwischen den demokratinnen und
demokraten in diesem haus eigentlich
auch mehr gemeinsames als trennendes und
das schließt natürlich auch nicht
notwendige debatte über den richtigen
weg aus dass wird es sicherlich braucht
bei ihrem aktionsplan frau ministerin in
den kommenden monaten geben aber es muss
doch eines klar sein hier heute bei
dieser aktuellen stunde der
rechtsextremismus in deutschland er darf
keine chance
und die gewaltspirale
sie dreht sich ja leider immer weiter
und schneller und damit verbunden auch
die radikalisierungstendenzen in den
sozialen netzwerken und der
besorgniserregende anstieg der zügellose
hass gegen bürgermeister und andere
mandatsträger darunter im übrigen auch
viele ehrenamtlich in der
kommunalpolitik sei an dieser stelle
auch noch mal erwähnt denn auch hier
dürfen wir uns nicht wegducken denn dass
die kommunalpolitische arbeit das
kommunalpolitische ehrenamtliche wirken
das ist die wurzel unserer demokratie
und es gilt daher auch die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer
sicherheitsbehörden weiter zu erhalten
aber
neben den verbesserten kooperation
zwischen den sicherheitsbehörden geht es
mir heute auch mal darum eine deutliche
wertschätzung unserer polizei und
unseres verfassungsschutzes die leisten
nämlich in eine hervorragende und gute
arbeit es sind die beamtinnen und
beamten die für unsere sicherheit und
freiheit jeden tag auf die straße gehen
und auch leib und leben riskieren
diese kolleginnen und kollegen zwei
jahre nach andermatt uns dieser
terroranschlag immer noch zum handeln
wir stehen hier in der verantwortung den
opfern aber natürlich auch den
angehörigen der toten gegenüber wir
können und wollen das tun die cdu csu
fraktion wird sich weiterhin mit aller
schärfe gegen jede form von extremismus
wären hierbei ist und für uns klar der
rechtsextremismus ist derzeit die größte
bedrohung für die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung das bedeutet
aber nicht dass wir uns auch mit allen
formen des extremismus
auseinandersetzen herzlichen dank
michael breilmann war das neue
abgeordnete kommt aus nordrhein
westfalen er ist gerade seit dieser
woche von seiner fraktion der cdu csu
fraktion benannt worden
als beiratsmitglied im bündnis für
demokratie und toleranz gegen
extremismus und gewalt das gibt es ja
seit 2000 ist man vom
bundesinnenministerium initiiert worden
und verfolgt als nicht volatil
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement für
demokratie und toleranz das weise zu
bündeln und zu vernetzen
nächste rednerin china gaben mir ist das
für die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren zitat mein sohn soll
nicht umsonst gestorben sein zitat ende
das herz rp tennis um mutter des
ermordeten fährt und weil mir am sonntag
auf der bundesversammlung gesagt ich
kann wie viel kraft es den angehörigen
und überlebenden kostet den anstehenden
zweiten jahrestag des rechts
terroristischen anschlags in hanau zu
begehen wie viel schmerz und leid sie
täglich empfinden durch den verlust
ihrer geliebten angehörigen und
freundinnen wie viel kraft es sie kostet
darum zu kämpfen dass die vielen offenen
fragen rund um den 19 24 20 endlich
beantwortet werden auch wie anstrengend
es sein muss die erinnerung wach zu
halten die uns allen mahnung ist dass
rassismus entmenschlicht ausgrenzt
verletzt und tötet
den angehörigen und überlebenden geht
mein tiefstes mitgefühl meine und unsere
solidarität und ich bewundere sie für
ihre stärke
aus eigener erfahrung weiß ich wie viel
ausdauer es braucht ständig dafür zu
kämpfen dass anerkannt wird wie tief
rassismus in unserer gesellschaft
verwurzelt ist und immer wieder erklären
zu müssen was es heißt mit rassismus
konfrontiert zu sein und davon bedroht
zu werden
ich sage den angehörigen und
überlebenden hier und heute wir stehen
an ihrer seite
nicht nur an diesem tag sondern auch an
den anderen 364 tagen im jahr
mein sohn soll nicht umsonst gestorben
sein diese worte haben mich tief bewegt
doch in all ihrer traurigkeit sind sie
auch voller willenskraft und tatendrang
und sie sind nur ein beispiel für all
das was die angehörigen und überlebenden
in den letzten zwei jahren bewirkt haben
wie sie immer ansprechbar waren für die
öffentlichkeit und für uns politiker in
damit sich in diesem land endlich
grundlegend etwas ändert damit wir hass
und rassismus endlich strukturell
bekämpfen aber auch damit dass der
umgang mit opfern und hinterbliebenen
von rassistischer gewalt und terror
englisch empathischer und würdiger
gestaltet wird
ich stehe hier weil ich ihnen und all
den anderen angehörigen und überlebenden
von rassistischen anschlägen und
übergriffen sagen will hier tut sich was
hier kommen wir wirklich vorwärts
aber das geht nur wenn unsere
gesellschaft ein grundwissen über
rassismus hat und akzeptiert dass
rassismus aktiv verlernt werden muss
sowohl institutionelle als auch jeder
und jede für sich persönlich
auch denn auch im jahr 2022 gibt es noch
so viele menschen die entweder glauben
wir hätten gar kein rassismus problem
oder die selbst rassistische einstellung
teilen anders kann ich es mir nicht
erklären warum eine 17 jährige mitten in
berlin in einer straßenbahn aus
rassistischen motiven angegriffen wird
und niemand
ergreift oder zu hilfe kommt
wenn ich mir diesen bundestag oder
jedenfalls teile davon anschaue dann
kann ich feststellen dass wir diverse
aufgestellt sind als jemals zuvor
menschen mit einwanderungsgeschichte und
rassismus erfahrung wie ich selbst sind
hier oder endlich im kabinett vertreten
diese diversität ist das fundament
unserer stärke und unseren zusammenhalt
das ist ein anfang
denn wir sind stimme und einfluss für
all jene die hier zu hause sind und den
teilhabe gleiche rechte gleiche
sicherheit bisher viel zu oft verwehrt
wurden weil ihre namen anders klingen
oder aufgrund ihrer vermeintlichen
herkunft wir sind stimme und einfluss
für eine konsequente anti rassistische
politik mit wirksamen maßnahmen deswegen
werden wir zum beispiel ein demokratie
fördergesetz auf den weg bringen wir
werden das allgemeine
gleichbehandlungsgesetz
verbessern und ja eine verschärfung des
waffenrechts gehört auch dazu damit
stehen wir weichen für erkennbare
nachhaltige veränderungen
[Musik]
wir werden einen langen atem brauchen
aber wir sind es den angehörigen und
überlebenden des anschlags in hanau und
all den anderen opfern rechtsextremer
und rassistischer einschlägige schuldig
fördert unwahr und die anderen sollen
nicht umsonst gestorben vielen dank
hier war das neue abgeordnete ist für
die nordrhein westfälischen grünen in
den bundestag eingezogen
und der nächste redner in der debatte
ist konstantin kohler fdp-fraktion und
jetzt ist hier aufgerufen constantin
kohle für die fdp frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren der deutsche bundestag
gedenkt heute der opfer des
rechtsextremen terrorakts von hanau vor
zwei jahren und wenn wir heute über
dieses ereignis debattieren dann müssen
wir zunächst über die opfer sprechen der
anschlag von hanau betraf in erster
linie menschen die selbst oder deren
familien nach deutschland eingewandert
sind und damit steht der anschlag in
hanau in einer reihe mit den morden des
sogenannten nationalsozialistischen
untergrund ist denn auch die taten des
sogenannten nsu richteten sich in erster
linie gegen menschen mit
migrationshintergrund wenn man selber
keine vorfahren hat die nach deutschland
eingewandert sind wenn man selber selten
oder niemals für jemanden gehalten wird
der einen migrationshintergrund hat oder
der beispielsweise muslimische ist dann
kann man sich nur sehr schwer vorstellen
wie die taten des nsu und wie der
anschlag von hanaus sich auf das
sicherheitsgefühl bestimmt da individuen
und bestimmter gruppen in deutschland
ausgewirkt hat ich will aber auch sagen
liebe frau kollegin gambia die
bekämpfung von rassismus und
rechtsextremismus ist nicht nur die
aufgabe von politikerinnen und
politikern mit fraktions hintergrund
sondern ist die aufgabe von allen
politikerinnen und politikern und das
müssen wir gemeinsam hier aus diesem
haus verlangen
dazu gehört dass wir die
sicherheitsbedenken der betroffenen
communitys ernst nehmen dazu gehört dass
wir auch in der ausbildung von
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten
stärker darauf drängen dass es eine
sensibilität für die berechtigten
sicherheitsinteressen dieser gruppen
gibt und dazu gehört ein neuer umgang
mit opfern der kollege staatssekretär
straße hatte sagt es gibt leider immer
mehr opfer terroristischer gewalttaten
in unserem land und ich bin auch dem
neuen beauftragten der bundesregierung
pascal kober dankbar dass er bereits
konkrete vorschläge gemacht hat etwa im
hinblick auf den leichteren zugang zur
entschädigungsleistung meine damen und
herren wenn wir über die tat von hanau
sprechen dann müssen wir über die opfer
sprechen wir müssen aber auch über die
radikalisierung geschichte des täters
sprechen denn nicht jedes motiv dass der
täter in seinem pamphleten in seinen
manifesten verbreitet hat lässt sich
eindeutig den rechtsextremismus und
lässt sich eindeutig dem rassismus
zuordnen wenn man sich das anschaut wenn
man sich das durchliest dann verbreitete
der täter auch verschwörungs mythen die
auf den ersten blick oder wenn sie
isoliert auftreten verrückt oder
abseitig herüberkommen aber es ist eben
genau dieses zusammenspiel aus
verschwörungs erzählungen und
gewaltorientierten extremistischen
radikalisierungsprozess dass die
besondere gefährlichkeit von tätern wie
im fall des anschlags von hanau aus
macht und es gibt ganz akute
überlappungen von verschwörungs mitten
auf der einen seite und von
radikalisierung auf der anderen seite
die einfachen erklärungen für komplexe
sachverhalte die einteilung der welt in
gut und böse es gibt zahlreiche studien
ältere die neue die sich ganz besonders
auseinandersetzen mit dieser überlappung
von verschwörungs mythen und von
radikalisierung und genau diese
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse die
müssen endlich ankommen in unseren
sicherheitsbehörden die müssen teil der
ausbildung sein die müssen teil der
personalauswahl seien es sehr gut wenn
der juristen arbeiten aber da müssen
auch leute arbeiten die ein verständnis
für internationale digitale radikale
codes die das lesen und verstehen können
und ein gespür dafür entwickeln wenn
sich in unserem land etwas zusammenbraut
und ich bin dankbar dass diese
erkenntnisse dass diese gewissheit jetzt
auch im bundesinnenministerium
angekommen sind mutter und
lassen sie mich auch etwas zu den
politischen konsequenzen insgesamt sagen
wir stehen am beginn einer neuen
legislaturperiode
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode der
neunzehnten gab es neben dem
rechtsextremen anschlag von hanau im
februar 2022 den antisemitisch
motivierten anschlag von halle im
oktober 2009 10 vier monate zuvor wurde
der kasseler regierungspräsident und cdu
politiker weiter lübke von einem
rechtsextremisten erschossen und die
neunzehnte wahlperiode des deutschen
bundestages war damit ganz klar
gekennzeichnet von mehreren tödlichen
rechtsextremistischen anschlägen und
deswegen ist es auch total richtig das
zu beginn der zwanzigsten wahlperiode
eine neue bundestagsmehrheit und eine
neue bundesregierung sagt das ist jetzt
unser schwerpunkt erinnern wir uns doch
einmal zurück an die zeit vor zwei
legislaturperioden wert der achtzehnten
wahlperiode am 19 dezember 2016 da gab
es den islamistischen anschlag am
berliner breitscheidplatz es starben 13
menschen und infolge dieser tat war in
der darauffolgenden legislaturperiode
die bekämpfung des islamismus ein ganz
zentrales anliegen dieses deutschen
bundestages und der bundesregierung und
das war richtig so aber war der damen
und herren einen arbeitsschwerpunkt auf
ein konkretes oder akutes problem hier
den rechtsextremismus zu richten
bedeutet nicht andere formen des
extremismus zu vernachlässigen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden und unsere
innenpolitik sind auf keinem auge blind
es muss aber möglich sein über konkrete
maßnahmen zu sprechen das analysetool
radler rechts für rechtsextreme
gefährder muss fertig werden wir
brauchen eine gesetzliche grundlage für
das gemeinsame terrorismusabwehrzentrum
und das gemeinsame extremismus und
terrorismus abwehrzentrum im bereich des
rechtsextremismus und wir brauchen auch
eine konsequente entwaffnung von
rechtsextremisten und reichs bürgern auf
der basis des geltenden zu machen und
meine damen und herren deswegen ist der
satz jeder
extremismus ist schlimm es gibt keinen
guten extremismus so richtig wie banal
wir sind es aber den ort von jedes
terroristen kommen sie zum schluss den
ursachen für die tat genau auf den grund
zu gehen und künftig derartige anschläge
zu vermeiden und das sind wir auch den
opfern von hanno schuldig vielen dank
und zu seiner ersten rede erteile ich
das wort lennart öl spd-fraktion
ändert ist ordnete für den wahlkreis
hanau und umgebung sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren sie haben recht ist es meine
erste rede im deutschen bundestag
ich spreche aber nicht nur als neuer
abgeordneter heute zu ihnen sondern auch
als direkt gewählte abgeordnete des
wahlkreises hanau deshalb ist es mir ein
besonderes anliegen heute zu dieser
aktuellen stunde zu sprechen ich sehe es
als verpflichtung
als verpflichtung gegenüber den
angehörigen der opfer die ihre liebsten
durch einen rassistisch motivierten
anschlag verloren haben aber auch
allgemein als verpflichtung gegenüber
allen hanauerinnen und hanauer die ich
im bundestag vertreten und für die der
neunzehnte februar nie mehr ein normaler
tag sein wird ich bin der nato zur
schule gegangen und sicherlich hunderte
male über den hanauer heimat gelaufen
heute schnürt es mir jedes mal die kehle
zu wenn ich über den hanauer heumarkt
laufe einen der beiden anschlagsorte so
geht es wahrscheinlich tausenden
hanauerinnen und hanauer um gleichwohl
unzählige menschen mit dem rassistischen
anschlag eigene emotionen verbinden so
ist dies jedoch nicht zu vergleichen mit
dem unvorstellbaren leid dass die
angehörigen durchleiden müssen es
berührt mich persönlich sehr wie die
angehörigen ihre trauer auf
unterschiedliche art und weise
verarbeiten und mit eigenen initiativen
würdiges erinnern ermöglichen
ich finde es bewundernswert
auch nach so einem harten start
schicksalsschlag nach wie vor hoffnung
in unsere zivilgesellschaft zu haben
deshalb begrüße er ist das aufgrund des
zweiten jahrestages der anschlag thema
der aktuellen stunde ist denn es gibt
mir die möglichkeit hier im bundestag
auch mal deutlich zu machen dass wir vor
ort in hanau eigentlich konkret zur
trauerbewältigung leisten können da
steht natürlich im vordergrund die
betreuung der abt betroffenen familien
durch die stadt hanau aber auch als
aktuell das schaffen eines würdigen
gedenkens in der stadt und natürlich die
besondere entwicklung neuer angebote wir
wollen in hanau mit dem zentrum für
demokratie und vielfalt hanno einen
lebendigen salon einrichten für debatten
einer bunten gesellschaft damit soll der
zusammenhalt der hanauer
zivilgesellschaft unterstützt werden
denn der anschlag war ein anschlag auf
die werte die diese stadt und ihre
bürger schafft lebt bei der beerdigung
von ethnischer haschemi und hansa coach
fand oberbürgermeister claus kaminsky
die passenden worte
diese beiden opfer waren keine fremden
sie waren hanauer buben
ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass ayla
coach die schwester des ermordeten hamza
kultur wird am vergangenen sonntag teil
der bundesversammlung war wir stehen in
regelmäßigem kontakt und sie gab mir für
die heutige rede folgenden appell mit
sorgen sie sehr geehrte politiker dafür
dass die umstände dieses schrecklichen
verbrechens restlos aufgeklärt und die
entsprechenden lehren daraus gezogen
werden damit sich so eine tat nicht
wiederholen kann
diesen appell den einer kultur witsch an
ihrer rede an der zentralen trauerfeier
am 4 märz 2020 das erste mal an die
öffentlichkeit richtete hat an seiner
aktualität leider nicht verloren wenn
wir über die verarbeitung des anschlages
sprechen dann dürfen wir die politische
aufarbeitung nicht vergessen ich bin zur
ems weser deswegen sehr dankbar dass sie
die aufarbeitung im hessischen landtag
in den letzten zwei jahren stets
vorangetrieben hat und seit ihrem ersten
amtstag als bundesinnenminister in dem
rechtsextremismus in ganz deutschland
den kampf angesagt hat
doch auch im untersuchungsausschuss des
hessischen landtags werden aktuell die
landespolitikerin und landespolitiker
mit den fragen der angehörigen
konfrontiert
hätte der anschlag verhindert werden
können der täter ist bereits im vorfeld
auffällig gewesen durch rassistische
äußerungen
trotzdem konnte er in heißen nach wie
vor einen waffenschein besitzen welche
pannen unterliefen den
sicherheitsbehörden im einsatz warum war
der notruf technisch so veraltet dass
anrufe der opfer nicht durchkamen warum
waren allgemein notausgänge am tatort in
kesselstadt blockiert diesen fragen der
angehörigen müssen wir nachgehen wer
diesen fragen nicht ernsthaft nachgeht
kann nicht behaupten genug gegen
rassismus und rechten terror zu
unternehmen
deshalb ist es unsere moralische pflicht
diesen fragen antworten zu liefern in
hanau in wiesbaden aber auch hier in
berlin vielen dank
[Applaus]
und ich hatte das wort dr stefan hack
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir sind langsam am
ende dieser debatte ich will deshalb nur
wenige ergänzende anmerkungen machen
zunächst finde ich es ist gut dass bei
diesem wichtigen und auch sensiblen
thema er unter den großen und
demokratischen fraktionen diesem haus
eine große einigkeit haben
der neunzehnter februar 2020
war eine dunkelsten tage in der jüngeren
geschichte der bundesrepublik und er war
auch einer der dunkelsten tage in der
jüngeren geschichte meines heimat
bundeslandes essen es ist richtig und es
ist wichtig dass der deutsche bundestag
heute kurz vor dem zweiten jahrestag die
gelegenheit nimmt auch hier an dieser
stelle noch einmal daran zu erinnern an
diesem 19 februar wir haben das gehört
hat der täter kaltblütig und innerhalb
kürzester zeit neun junge menschen aus
der blüte ihres lebens gerissen er hat
anschließend seine mutter getötet und
sich selbst gerichtet und sich damit
auch der aufarbeitung einem
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren entzogen es
waren neun junge menschen die noch so
viel vorhanden und wir werden sie nicht
vergessen nicht in hanau nicht in hessen
und auch nicht hier im deutschen
bundestag
es ist erste pflicht des staates die
angehörigen nicht alleine zu lassen in
ihrem leid aber auch mit ihren
berechtigten fragen deswegen hat der
generalbundesanwalt sehr ausführlich
ermittelt und deshalb ist es richtig
dass auch ein untersuchungsausschuss im
hessischen landtag sich mit den noch
offenen fragen beschäftigt und es war
gut dass hessen hier sehr schnell
reagiert hat und neben der opfer
entschädigung ein sonderförderprogramm
für hanau mit insgesamt 600.000 euro
aufgelegt hat aber meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren unsere verantwortung
geht darüber hinaus es gibt dem
demokratischen rechtsstaat niemals
hundertprozentige sicherheit aber
auftrag des staates ist es den
bestmöglichen schutz für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger zu gewährleisten
und frau bundesministerin feser sie
haben recht politische bildung ist ein
teil der antwort darauf aber es ist eben
nicht alles
und damit sind wir bei einer sehr
politischen frage wie stellen wir unsere
sicherheitsbehörden auf damit sie mit
diesen herausforderungen
zurechtkommen wir haben eben vom
kollegen coole sehr eindrucksvoll gehört
was diesen täter von anderen
unterscheidet es gibt offenbar einen
neuen tätertyp in hanau ähnlich wie in
halle der sich radikalisiert nicht in
vereinigung die von unseren
verfassungsschutzbehörden beobachtet
werden sondern eher in der isolation und
scheinbar zurückgezogen das findet nicht
auf marktplätzen statt sondern in räumen
in denen wir zunächst keinen zugang
haben und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir heute auch über die frage sprechen
welche instrumente unsere
sicherheitsbehörden brauchen um hier auf
die richtigen antworten zu finden und da
muss man leider sagen dass das was im
koalitionsvertrag steht nicht die
richtige antwort ist das was sie dort
niedergeschrieben haben ist er ein
manifest des misstrauens gegen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden sie leben die online
untersuchung ab sie lehnen die quellen
täter ab und auch eine personelle
perspektive für die ausstattung unserer
sicherheitsbehörden fehlt frau
bundesministerin wir kennen uns aus
hessen sie standen immer wieder auch
gegen widerstände in ihrer eigenen
partei
engagiert auf der seite der beamtinnen
und beamten ich möchte ihnen heute zu
rufen setzten sie sich gegen die
bedenkenträger in dieser koalition
durchstarten sie die sicherheitsbehörden
mit ihren möglichkeiten aus die sie
brauchen uns haben sie dabei an ihrer
seite herzlichen dank
stefan hack in dieser aktuellen stunde
mit
der der bundestag heute ja nicht nur an
hanau erinnert sondern an eine spur des
rechten terroristen mehr forschung sagt
wurden roche spd-fraktion die mord serie
des netzwerkes der mord an walter lübcke
der ist rechtsextrem ist motivierter
angriff auf die synagoge in hanau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren und sehr geehrte angehörige der
opfer des rechts terroristischen
anschlages von hanau ich werde den namen
ihrer verstorbenen nicht vergessen und
ich glaube dass in dieser debatte
deutlich geworden ist dass wir alle die
demokratinnen und demokraten in diesem
haus die namen der opfer des anschlages
nicht vergessen werden wer hat um war
mercedes coupe budget
kürbis gekannt gültekin haben djokovic
kalorien welt will kuhn
zeitmesser haschemi und fatih karabulut
genauso wie wir die nsu mordopfer nicht
vergessen werden keinen einzigen sie
sind uns allen mahnung und auftrag denn
sie sind die opfer der größten gefahr in
unserem land geworden sie sind allesamt
opfer des rechts terrorismus geworden
und wir werden auch nie vergessen wie
rassistisch und einseitig die polizei
ermittlungen bei den nsu morgen waren
die morde angehörige als beschuldigte
und so weiter
auch die angehörigen der mordopfer von
hana mussten sich anhören dass an der
tat des wahnsinnigen märkte
flüchtlingspolitik schuld sei und zb vom
damaligen fdp vorsitzenden jörg leuten
und seine parteikollegen mussten sie
hören dass es sich eben nicht um rechten
terror sondern und die tat eines irren
handle und das hatten wir in dieser
debatte heute in gleicher weise gleich
noch mal gehört einzig treter theorie
also
und ich dachte nach all den
untersuchungsausschüssen bundesweit und
in den länderparlamenten wäre ein für
alle mal klar dass wir rechts
terroristische strukturen und netzwerke
in unserem land haben mit fast 14.000
gewaltbereiten und bewaffneten neonazis
und 76 rechten gefährdern von denen
jeder einzelne eine tickende zeitbombe
ist wer aber von diesen konkreten gefahr
nicht sprechen möchte der kann sie
natürlich auf der anderen seite auch
nicht bekämpfen und ja das stimmt der
hack es ist die erste pflicht des
staates sich um die opfer derartiger
anschläge zu kümmern und deshalb ist es
ja so beschämend dass den angehörigen
nach dem anschlag von hanau nicht sofort
die unterstützung und behandlung vor
allem aus einer hand
erfahren wurde die angemessen wäre und
das war nicht zuletzt ihre zuständigkeit
die zuständigkeit der regierung die sie
am tattag angehört haben das tut mir
persönlich und uns allen sehr leid und
ich bin froh dass die heutige
bundesinnenminister den damals so
schnell unsere nah bei den angehörigen
der opfer bau nichts was wir als staat
tun können liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen bringt den angehörigen die
verstorbenen zurück oder lindert gar ihr
leid aber vielleicht und ich danke allen
die heute appelle und zitate der
angehörigen der opfer vorgelesen haben
aber vielleicht finden sie trost in dem
wissen dass wir demokratinnen und
demokraten hier im deutschen bundestag
und in vielen anderen parlamenten dieses
landes alles tun werden damit sich
derartige monströse taten wie die von
hanau nicht wiederholen
ich darf sagen wir haben die
sicherheitsbehörden heck schon so
aufgestellt dass sie auf derartige täter
phänomene regieren können wir haben
ihnen schon die instrumente an die hand
gegeben die sicherheitsbehörden haben
schon ihre strukturen diesem täter typus
angepasst und mit verlaub dass gerade
sie das heute sagen verwundert mich
etwas ich sie ihr bundesland hessen und
ihre hessische landesregierung gerade
nicht als den vorkämpfer und die
speerspitze im kampf gegen rechts
terrorismus die mitglieder des eines
untersuchungsausschusses um andere in
ihrem landtag wissen von der sich
brechen alle wichtigen thema für staaten
geben
wir haben uns in der koalition darauf
die reine und im koalitionsvertrag so
aufgeschrieben dass wir die massnahmen
gegen hass im netz verschärfen werden
mit mehr prävention aber auch mit einem
schärferen schwert des rechtsstaates es
sind eben nicht nur worte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen unser
koalitionsvertrag das was wir tun das
ist konkrete arbeit im kampf gegen
rechts terrorismus zu lange hat dieser
stark rechten terror nicht wahrgenommen
im schlimmsten fall sogar ignoriert aber
ich versichere ihnen und damit komme ich
zum schluss dass für mich und meine
partei und alle demokratinnen und
demokraten in diesem land und in unserer
koalition und für die
bundesinnenministerium der kampf gegen
rechts oberste priorität hat weiter
rechts terrorismus die größte gefahr in
diesem land war und bleibt vielen dank
die kreuzfahrt es für die spd gegen
letzte redner in dieser aktuellen stunde
dass die namen der opfer von hanau nicht
vergessen sind das haben zahlreiche
abgeordnete heute deutlich gemacht die
namen genannt die ermittlungen der
bundesanwaltschaft die sind zwar ende
dezember eingestellt worden aber es ist
ja deutlich geworden dass viele fragen
der angehörigen bleiben einen
untersuchungsausschuss im hessischen
landtag unter anderem soll er aufklären
aber es gibt auch auf bundesebene auch
das ist heute noch mal deutlich geworden
initiativen beispielsweise wenn man an
dass demokratie fördergesetz denkt oder
auch zum verbot von waffen besitzt die
eine reaktion nicht nur auf diesen
anschlag sondern auf die spur des
rechten terrors der letzten jahre geben
sollen das war's für heute morgen melden
wenn es wieder live hier aus dem
deutschen bundestag ab 8 uhr 45 jetzt
geht's weiter in bonn mit meiner
kollegin claudia debus
vielen dank jeanette klag für die
berichterstattung aus berlin aus dem
bundestag lieber zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sie sehen es an unserem
kleinen vorschaufenster wir warten auf
die pressekonferenz nach der bund länder
runde aus berlin wir erwarten den
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hendrik wüst
den vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und auch
franz